hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today we are talking
about metabolism do you remember the
days where you could eat a sheet of
cookies for dinner and not see or feel
the impact ah yes
those were good times well fast-forward
to adulthood and everyone and their
mother are looking for the magic pill
help you stop the metabolic decline and
if you read bogus nutrition blogs and
sensationalized headlines you'll start
to notice that there are a lot of
supposed magic foods and easy tricks
that they're cleaning to help you burn
more calories without having to change
anything else about your lifestyle
thankfully I've dug deep into the
research to determine which one's work
best I've rated all the most popular
metabolism boosting recommendations on a
scale from zero to three calorie burning
flames breathing the most likely to rev
up your metabolism and zero council
welcome to part one breakfast this bad
boy gets one flame we've all been told
that breakfast is the most important
meal of the day
supposedly because it jump-starts your
metabolism after an overnight fast we've
pretty much just accepted this gospel as
truth but the reality shows that the
research is riddled with bias to add to
the confusion a small randomized control
trial actually found that even breakfast
doesn't necessarily have a significant
impact on resting metabolism and
actually it may not even impact how much
our gonna eat later on the day I still
think there are plenty good reasons to
enjoy a healthy breakfast like more
stable blood sugars that are daytime
performance and more mindful eating
habits throughout the day but it's still
too early to be able to call this a
great metabolism booster weight training
this gets three flames skipping the
weight room is a major moved a muscle is
about three times more metabolically
active than fat so it's pretty well
accepted knowledge that the more muscle
mass you have the higher your metabolism
so try adding one two three weight
training sessions throughout the week to
help protect your metabolism as you age
coconut oil that's gonna get one flame
the dye industry has gone cuckoo for
cocoa oil mainly thanks to its levels of
medium chain fatty acids which is a
saturated fat that is processed and
stored differently than other fat while
there have been some small studies that
have shown that coconut oil may have
some thermal
Janak effects compared to other fats
which means that may require a little
bit more energy or calories to digest
the sample sizes have been small and the
effects have been so negligible it's
really not worth fussing about bottom
line if you want to substitute some
butter or a vegetable oil for coconut
oil go for it but coconut oil still has
a hundred calories per tablespoon so
don't go downing the stuff thinking it's
gonna magically burn away your fat
Coffee one flame the caffeine properties
of coffee have been studied extensively
for their potential metabolism boosting
benefits but the studies have been
really small and really the effects have
been quite meager when that coffee is
actually consumed in normal healthy
amounts plus if you put cream or sugar
in your coffee
you're very quickly gonna undo the
metabolic game bottom line guys drink
coffee because you want to wake the hell
up not to lose weight uh guys no magic
pills there but stay tuned for part two
of my metabolism series thank you so
much for watching if you liked what you
saw be sure to subscribe to my channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen
you